eth council conference here in
luxembourg you presented the early
findings of a unique new study tell us
what some of the highlights were of that
probe and for all is a big topic at this
event and it's been a big topic at this
event for many iterations we think and
we want to demonstrate through the
analysis that the prevailing model to
extend broadband as further out into a
given country as possible is not really
working and we think that there's a
better model that would require a lot
less public subsidies basically the
prevailing model is a private operator
says well this is how far I'll go this
is how far it's profitable for me to go
in terms of fiber deployment and then
the government comes in and says well
I'll subsidize you to go further so that
determines kind of a second threshold
and anything beyond that no one really
knows how is going to be addressed we
believe that instead if instead of
turning to a private operator to do that
we were looking at infrastructure
companies to do that we could get most
of that territory covered in fact
possibly more territory covered than the
subsidized version of the prevailing
model without any subsidies so so are we
saying if we see ftth is purely
infrastructure will get like nationwide
cover there are some caveats because in
any geography there are a few outliers
that are so complicated to connect that
you do have to consider alternative
methods etc but that should be five
percent of the territory not twenty five
percent of surgery or fifty five percent
of the territory depending on the cases
the other caveat is that infrastructure
requires specific business model
considerations the investors are in it
for the long term and they want to have
certainty of profitability and in order
to do that the prevailing regulatory
model is probably not adapted because
price regulation has reviewed every
three years and depending on changes
within the regulator's organizations or
whatever you can have pretty radical
shifts in price regulation and the types
of shareholders that will invest
massively in infrastructure are very
unhappy with that and so we believe that
in order for this model to work you
would also need to look at acid-based
regulation the way for example that
water and electricity are currently
regulated where what is capped is not
the price it's the amount of profit that
the operation can do and that creates a
virtuous circle because excess profit
has to be reinvested which means more
infrastructure so it creates this kind
of dynamic we're deploying more
infrastructure is an integral part of
the business model it's not anything new
in a sense so are you confident it might
happen what what do you think what do
you think it'll take for people to look
at this business model I think first of
all policymakers need to understand that
they have been they haven't been
subsidizing more broadband they've been
subsidizing companies that are not well
suited to deploy infrastructure so that
they could deploy infrastructure so they
have to understand that and they have to
understand that it's a market structure
issue more than an inherent issue of
fiber fiber in and of itself is not
expensive because expensive is a
definition of you know a private market
player saying well this is too much and
I can't do it but that depends on who
the market player is so first of all
they have to realize that and second
they need a certain amount of political
courage to say well sure existing
players are happy with the market
structure but it's not delivering what
we need for our country and so it has to
change now the good news is in some
previous analysis we looked at the
impact of structural separation for
shareholders of telecom companies and
actually that impact is massively
positive so we're just at the very
beginning of this whole education piece
but we believe that all of the parties
actually have only positives in this
consideration it's just it because it's
a big shift it's going to take some time
well let's hope we get there thanks very
much for joining us you're welcome